so und philipp deine welt ist die
meinung ja also muss sich deutschland zu
dieser stunde am meisten auch ich weiß
nicht ob deutschland sich einer sache
schon bewusst geworden ist ich habe das
zumindest von der cdu bislang noch nicht
gehört man spricht schon jetzt über eine
mögliche regierungsbildung will ins
kanzleramt einziehen aber ich glaube den
menschen ist noch nicht ganz klar
geworden was eine cdu niederlage in
teilen des landes wirklich bedeutet und
vor allem wenn man mal in den osten
schaut ich würde gern mal einmal mein
laptop umdrehen da sieht man nämlich die
wahlkreise in sachsen die erststimme in
sachsen und diese karte ist blau und
blau ist die afd das ist eine
rechtsextreme partei die in sachsen
davon profitiert massiv davon profitiert
dass die cdu komplett abschmiert das
haben die menschen in sachsen ist haben
ganz deutschland der cdu viel zu
verdanken und federführend natürlich
armin laschet das gäbe es ansonsten
nicht das land ist eigentlich
tiefschwarz da hat eigentlich michael
kretschmer der ministerpräsident letztes
mal noch relativ souverän die wahl
gewonnen und dieses land ist jetzt afd
blau bei den zweitstimmen liegt die cdu
in sachsen auf platz drei nach der spd
nach der afd das ist grauenvoll und
diese folgen wie wird man eigentlich
noch aufarbeiten müssen hoffe ich
zumindest danke für diesen wichtigen
blick auch eine ganz wichtige erzählung
[Musik]